welcome everybody I'm going to talk
about
web design for developers and well let's
start with a question first how many of
you are working for a web agency who has
like an art director and some web
designers okay only one so that's pretty
good
for this session at least and I mean the
rest of you are doing web development
but you have to figure pretty much out
yourself how to make it look good and do
the how the look and feel of your
application I guess so
well that's the reason to do this
session because I have been working for
a web pages for about ten years and I
had like to deal with our directors and
web designers and I'm like a technical
guy and I can promise you one thing
those people are a special piece of work
I mean they are very difficult to work
with and the reasons for having such
difficulties with those people is that
if we would take a look at the brains of
a developer it would probably look
something like this so if we would cut
up on our head and we look inside we
will see something like this and this is
more or less like creative but these
guys these are all people in case you
didn't notice they can do this any time
of the year
any minute of the day they can make this
pretty pictures all day long but if you
would take a look at the brains of a
designer Apple probably looks something
like this and I mean this can be done
only once it depends on the wind it
depends on the rain it depends on the
position of the moon I don't know
whatever if you ask a designer to do
this a second time it's gonna look
different and well for a lot of things
that's good but yeah for us that is
typically quite difficult because we
want to do it in a structured way and we
want to yeah
reproduce certain things a number of
times
so a
case you have not you don't have to deal
with those kind of brains there are a
couple of things that we can do to make
our sites or our web applications
basically look better without going into
Photoshop and doing all kinds of crazy
things with with with graphics and so on
so before we go into a bit of coding I
will do a bit of live coding and I will
show you a bit about CSS and how to make
your website look responsive that is
something which is yeah pretty obvious
these days in hex it has to look good on
all devices small and big ones I'm going
to show you a couple of tricks on how
that works but before we do I'll first
share a couple of trends that you see
these days on websites and one of the
things that is pretty pretty popular
these days is big scalable background
photography and well I've got one of our
own demo sites which is a small hotel
site and I can switch over to to the
live site as well it did change recently
slightly but it still has the idea of
big scalable photography because what
happens is if we make this site a bit
smaller you'll see that it will still
look good and things got rearranged a
bit you can obviously get those images
from a number of websites you can
purchase those images you have to be
careful with all the things that I'm
showing you have to be careful about
copyright issues but I'll speak a bit
about it a bit later you can acquire
those images or you can make them
yourself but you'll see this quite a bit
and what you see these days is that
they're personalised images as well
which is
for instance with big rotating banners
and the photography and if you take a
look at this side this side is actually
designed by one of my friends and she is
she is a designer but she is also pretty
into pretty much into responsive CSS and
all those kind of tricks and what you
see here is that they actually hired a
photographer to take a couple of
pictures of the people actually working
on this company don't mind the text I'm
from Holland so this is a Dutch site but
if you take a look at this side this is
one of the the better responsive sites I
don't have to say because what happens
here is they've got like this nice big
image but once I start resizing this
side and you take a look at the position
this is a site where you can search for
vacancies and job openings and stuff
like that but once I resize this site
you'll see that things start to
rearrange you'll see that the search box
gets smaller and if I make it even
smaller for a phone or whatever you'll
see that the navigation changed the form
disappeared it moved all the way to the
bottom so this is actually a pretty
advanced example of responsive web
design but you'll see that we can we can
do that ourselves I mean she spent quite
some time on getting this all working
perfectly but you'll see that the
navigation changed the position of
elements changed and this is all being
done with css3 and media queries which I
will talk about a bit later and the
interesting thing is that nothing is
being repainted or there is not
performed any JavaScript at this stage
this is all being done by CSS so this is
really fast because the browser knows
how to deal with CSS and yeah this is an
excellent example of a responsive side
so another thing that you see here and
there I would not advise you to go into
this this is typically something which
is used on design agency websites but I
thought it is still cool to show because
this is what's possible with CSS these
days does anybody know what parallax
scrolling is only one well I've got a
perfect example because as with a couple
of things in in current web development
ideas have been taken out of video
gaming from the from the early 80s and
the Super Nintendo games and stuff like
that and here you see you see one of
those games and this is an excellent
example of parallax scrolling what you
see is that the game is actually divided
into a couple of layers so you've got
the big mountain on the back we've got
like some smaller mountains on the front
and you've got the action figure all the
way on the front but what you see is
that those layers day shift at different
speeds so the back layered with a big
mountain and the clouds they move slower
as the layer in front of it and the
action figure even goes faster and that
gives you an impression of 3d on your
side and as I mentioned this is
something which can be applied on
websites as well but you'll need some
serious photography or some elements on
it so this is being done on some more
web design agency related sites but one
of the examples that uses this as well
which is not a web agency is the Space
Needle side of the Seattle Space Needle
so let me open that one up well this is
actually a pretty long needle in the sky
so this would be an excellent example
for parallax scrolling and what you see
here is that if I scroll down you see
different elements move at different
speeds you see and this will give you an
impression on that it is 3d and well
what you do see is that you need like
some specific photography in this case
so for us as developers I would not go
this path but this will show you the
power of css3 what is being used heavily
on this on this side together with a bit
of JavaScript so these are some some
things that you see on the more modern
websites but let's let's talk a bit more
about some things that we can use these
days and I will first start with
something which is introduced to use as
three which is called downloadable fonts
with before season 3 we only had the
availability of a number of fonts which
were also available on the on the
computer or the device of the visitor of
the site so you could have like aerial
or courier Madonna and a couple of other
fonts but those fonts needs to be
available so they need to be installed
on the computer that you're browsing the
web so in case your company has like
some corporate ID with some style guides
etc and they use a specific font you
couldn't be using that phones because it
needs to be installed on a workstation
or on the device but what css3 we can
use custom downloadable phones and what
that means is that we can put the font
definition file on the web server it
will be downloaded on the client machine
temporarily and you could have that font
of your company which is used in all
their communication you could use that
in your site as well and well this is
just a little example of a couple of
fonts that are not available on all
machines by default so this is something
that you could use and and this could be
one of the things to make your site a
bit more into the look and feel of the
corporate identity of the company that
you're working for I mean most companies
will have some style
which defines which phones they're using
which colors which logos etc etc this
could be something to be used so if you
want to use this downloadable fonts
thing there is another there is another
thing with the phones but I'll come to
that in a couple of minutes if you want
to have this available on your site you
need to have three font definitions to
support all major browsers so you will
have a WOFF file which has the form
definition how all the characters look
you will need to have an alt in case you
are still supporting some older Explorer
versions and you will also need a TT F
which is a true type font for Firefox
Chrome Opera and some other browsers I
would warn you because it might cost
copyright issues and I can tell you that
if you find a found somewhere on your
local machine for instance and you want
to make that available on the web server
you have to be careful that it is
allowed with that font I can promise you
that if you are putting the font on the
server the author of that font will find
you and he will notice you I had a I had
a project in the past and that was like
I still wonder how they found it I was
working for a company and we had to
create some some kind of a micro site
where you could win a prize which were
tickets to a concert of I think it was
Justin Bieber or something and the
agency who delivered all the content to
us they just googled a couple of images
of Justin Bieber they sent it over to us
they bought a couple of tickets with
some ticketing agency and that was the
prize so we put up that side
the site was live for like two hours we
got a message from the management of
Justin Bieber you have images on your
side that's not going to work yeah the
people are going to win a prize which
are tickets to Justin Bieber
take those images of they found it I
mean we I was working in Holland it was
a Dutch agency and they found it within
an hour so they will find those funds as
well so be careful with that but there
are obviously solutions for this if you
want to go that path
well here's by the way how you would
declare that in CSS but I'll show you a
bit later because I'm going to show you
a small example where we will use a
custom font which is copyright free so
you can use that so what you basically
do in CSS is that you will define a font
family you give it a name and you
specify those three formats that I was
mentioning earlier and then it will be
available under the font family name
that I specified there in CSS but you'll
see a bit later how that works so
getting back to the copyright thing
there is a solution for that which is
Google web fonts and let me get back was
a bit too fast the thing with the Google
web fonts is that they have a huge
collection of fonts but you have to
check that out because fonts normally
have a name which is kind of universal
like free Donna if you pick if you
search for a font for Donna it will look
like for Donna anyway
what they did with Google is they
changed names but the phones are still
looking the same so for instance if you
want to use for Donna or some other font
like I'm not really a fun kind of guy
but you have to find the alternative it
which looks the same so that they use a
bit of different names to overcome
copyright issues and stuff like that the
website of google fonts is actually
quite simple to to get on to because if
you just look for google web fonts or
google fonts
yeah that was not you will have on this
side available a huge collection of
fonts in all forms and shapes and if you
want to have one of those fonts
available on your site you can just
select it by adding this button add a
couple of more fonts may be and then
here you'll see how to import those
funds into your own site by just putting
this in the head and the font will be
available it's just as simple as that
in this case it will be named as real
way because I was not doing the real way
fund I think so if I specify in my CSS
somewhere a font family real way it will
use this font so it's pretty simple too
to get started with this I would be a
bit cautious by not going completely met
with those phones because yeah the
choice of fonts is normally being done
by some of these brains so I mean if you
have specifications you can just try to
use it or if not I would keep it safe
but another thing that comes with the
custom fonts is something which is more
interesting for us because how many of
you like doing stuff in paint or
Photoshop or making like little images
no one I knew that another thing which
comes with this is the use of icon fonts
somebody came up with the idea okay so
now we have custom fonts which are
basically all factor definitions on
those characters but what if I create a
specific font which will have little
icons or effector graphics icons glyphs
instead of characters ABC so that is
something which is pretty useful for us
because we didn't like to paint there
are a couple of providers with
I do with icon fonts and they are
basically these kinds of little symbols
for instance an Amazon logo or a battery
logo or a calendar or they've got plenty
of it and there are actually a couple of
providers of those I can so you don't
even need to draw them yourself you can
just go to one of those sites and in
this case I'll be showing the IQ moon
one which is a pretty a pretty yeah
familiar one you also have something
called font awesome which is like
something similar as this what you can
do here is you can actually select a
whole bunch of icons yourself and have
this side create a font definition for
you they have all kinds of stuff so for
instance if I go to the library here you
will have an enormous amount of all
kinds of images here and you can find
anyone anything you like and you can
have the sides have a font file composed
for you you can put it on your web
server link it in exactly the same way
as we did with the fonts and you can use
these little icons instead of drawing
them all by yourself one of the things
is because a full definition is a vector
formatted definition of those characters
the same applies to those icons they are
factor based images and that means that
if I want to have it bigger it will
remain crisp and clear it will not lose
any quality because there are not
bitmaps or g-packs anymore no there are
vector drawn images so they will always
be sharp and it will always look good
there is obviously one thing that you
should be aware of are basically two
because this is basically a font a font
has two colors a background and a
foreground the same applies to those
little to those icons they
only are in two colors available you can
change colors really easy by changing
the font color or the background color
you can change one of those colors in
HTML or CSS but if you need more colors
on those images yeah then the font icons
will not suit you because they yeah they
have a foreground and a background
that's about it another thing is it
could happen that for some reason this
font file can't be downloaded so
somebody is on a really crappy internet
connection he opens up his browser he
goes to your sides and that font needs
to be downloaded obviously if for some
reason that foam file cannot be served
or it cannot be downloaded you won't
have images it's just not going to be
there so you need to have aged a kind of
a fallback mechanism for that
and with those ICO moon and and form
awesome sites they provide you with some
some some good alternatives so as I
mentioned the size the colors they're
just going to be specified well you also
have to make sure that the minimum
browser supports the web fonts because
not the older browsers might have some
problems with this and you have to do
the fallback so you can do that by using
something called moderniser to determine
which browser supports this or you can
have a fallback mechanism of an image
sprite which contains all those images
and those sites that I was mentioning
they will provide you with a sprite
which seizes things in there as well so
you can still have a fallback mechanism
so talking about the the moderniser does
has anybody use modernizr sort of for
your just linking it in and it's being
done by facial studio so I'm just using
it does anybody know what it does
actually
well moderniser is like a really cool
thing to determine what capabilities
your browser has and the most easy way
to show that is
the only thing moderniser does its runs
a a small piece of JavaScript at the
loading of your page and what it does is
best to be shown in a screenshot of in
this case Firebug
you see a whole bunch of CSS selectors
on the HTML node of this document and
these nodes are these classes they have
been added by moderniser so modernizr is
a small piece of JavaScript it runs at
page load and it will add a number of
those tags here and for instance if you
want to know if your browser supports
SVG which is a factor based graphics
format in this case the browser supports
SVG because it just rendered a tag in
this this browser supports CSS gradients
yes it does
so whenever the browser does not support
SVG this one will be left out so this is
basically the only thing that moderniser
does so all the major features of the
browser are being rendered out as CSS
selectors so if I will now create a CSS
selector SVG that will only be done if
the browser supports SVG but you'll see
a bit later how that can be applied so
this is what moderniser does so this is
an excellent tool to determine what
capabilities your browser has concerning
ya all kinds of features that you can
use in the design of your site well I
was talking a bit about responsive web
design and it's the title of this this
session so I'm not gonna read this
I mean responsive web design is creating
a website which will look on which will
look good on all the different devices
that we have these days whether it is a
phone or a tablet or a desktop computer
or a laptop it should rearrange itself
depending on the device you're looking
at
so how could that be done well this is
basically a screenshot with show shoe
like okay so on the big screen it's
gonna look like that but on a small
screen I'm gonna put everything below
each other and in a nutshell that is
what can be done with things like
bootstrap or some other positioning
frameworks so yeah positioning frame CSS
frameworks that is something that you
should use to make sure that your site
looks good on any browser on any device
and well if we take a look at those
frameworks I would urge you to take one
of those frameworks whether it is
bootstrap or something else there are a
couple of other ones as well and
bootstrap is quite popular these days
I'll talk a bit about boot sir why it is
so popular there are obviously a lot of
designers familiar with bootstrap and
it's got a whole bunch of stuff there it
might not always be good because how
many of you are using third-party
controls from DevExpress or telluric or
any anything else yeah quite a few so
that might be an issue or that might
that might cause a bit of extra work
because you might need to have the
controls that come from the component
vendor to be looking in the same style
as bootstrap so that might be a reason
not to use bootstrap at the other end
it's it's widely used and it's really
easy to find somebody to work with
bootstrap as a developer another one
which is quite popular but not as
popular as bootstrap is foundation and
it supports pretty much the same
features as bootstrap it's it's got some
some some model of tools as you can see
and it's yeah it it's architecture so
it's slightly different but what you do
see is that it supports a grid system
and that is the same what Twitter is
using as well
the last one I want to show because I'm
going to do a bit of work on this one is
skeleton CSS is anybody familiar with
skeleton it's it's a really really
really small framework it doesn't have
all the bells and whistles of Twitter
but for me it gives me a good starting
point to show you what we can do for
responsive web design so I'm going to
use the skeleton one but I mean the same
principles apply to bootstrap and
foundation and any other great system as
well so how do they how do they work
I'll get to that a bit later because I'm
going to first tell you I have to move
this slide I'm going to be doing a bit
of coding in facial studio 2015 I'm
going to use the web studio the facial
studio web essentials plugin anyone
familiar with those yeah not too much
okay so if you're doing CSS HTML less
JavaScript I don't know whatever web
essentials is really is really a good
help but you'll see that in a minute
it's downloadable for free you can
install and use it for free as well and
it's absolutely for web development
something you should use I will be using
a browser in this case I'll probably be
using Firefox or Chrome because most
browsers have good developer tools so
getting back to the CSS positioning all
of those systems bootstrap foundation
skeleton they use a grid for positioning
and there are a couple of differences
between those grits for in but in in in
essence it works like this the CSS grid
system lays out a number of columns in
this case it lays out twelve columns
across your page and that means that you
can spend elements across those columns
if the page gets wider because you're
resizing your browser or you are looking
at it on a different device the columns
get wider if the screen gets smaller the
columns get small
and at a certain stage you can do some
things on that so we have two columns in
this case we picked 12 because it's
dividable by a large amount of numbers
you can divide it by 3 or 4 or 2 or
whatever some other grits your 16
columns so those are differences between
for instance bootstrap skeleton 1 uses
12 the other one uses 16 but we've got a
bunch of columns and then down those
columns we have bands or rows laid down
inside those rows we are putting
elements and what is interesting here is
that you'll see that we have a diff
which has a class with the name for and
we've got another one with the name of 8
and everything in one row should add up
to 12 in this case if you would have a
grid with 60 columns then you would have
a class 4 and you would have a class 12
so it will add up to the amount of
columns that's there well then you can
lay down a number of those row so it's a
bit like reporting you lay down a couple
of rows you put some content in there in
this case we'll have like a diff which
spends 12 and we've got some more and
you can create all kinds of variations
here you can knock yourself completely
out here and what happens if the screen
gets smaller elements will collapse or
drop down or will hide out so I could
say that for instance if my screen gets
smaller at a certain stage I want that
class 8 on the first row to disappear
completely that can be done with with
what css3 or I want to just have it
below the class 4 so those elements will
stick together or they will at least be
inside that road as a container and they
will span across those 12 columns so
that is basically the the baseline of
responsive web design and this is this
is how this is go
to work so I'm going to switch over to
my official studio here with the things
that I just shown you so I've got facial
studio I've got weapon sensors installed
and I have in this case downloaded the
skeleton framework I'll show you the
website really quick it's a really
minimalistic website you can download it
from here and it's got some some code
some examples and some other stuff here
and here you can see that they have the
columns laid out so I've set up a small
project the project doesn't involve a
lot of things here let me collapse that
one and the master pages is the main
setup here and what I further did I set
up a less files anybody familiar with
less sort of okay so less is basically a
a preprocessor for CSS and it allows us
to structure our CSS a bit better so for
instance we can use variables inside a
less file for a background color once we
save the less file that will be
converted to a CSS and it will replace
all those variables or all the places
with those variables and it will allow
us to set up CSS more quickly and it
also allows us to set up to reuse CSS on
various points so this is actually one
of the things why I use web essentials
because web essentials was able to
compile this into CSS so this is my last
file where I will start with and one of
the things that you see here is that we
will that we can use nested CSS and this
will once I save this let me make a
quick change here
you'll see that it will rearrange it you
see so this is basically what's what
less does so it allows us to create CSS
more quickly in a structured way another
thing that we can do is we can use
so-called mix-ins which is pretty much
like a CSS function so if we want to
have a drop shadow somewhere I can call
this particular less method here and it
will be rendered out with all the
vendor-specific shadow CSS things here
and I just downloaded this file and I'm
just gonna use it somewhere so it's yeah
it's it's quite a bit of time you've got
something else you've got less you've
got sass which is also like a CSS
processor I'm using less for this one
but it'sit's pretty much the same there
are some small differences there so I
also installed to speed up the coding
part of this session I have installed
code brush and I prepared a couple of
templates here so I don't need to type
too much code so as I mentioned I can
import the mix-ins less file so that
will be included and I will have the
functions all available and I was
talking about variables here so I am
declaring some some for and some
background colors here you'll declare
them by using the add sign with a name
and if I take a look right now at the
sides that we're looking at let me start
this one up then we'll have a fairly
simple side doesn't have any graphics
yet but it does have the responsive
features okay so what's going on here
all right there is
let me quickly comfort that
yeah I had to install a new version of
our own product and I'm using the menu
system that we have so I need to quickly
converted to have the new version
available here
it's going to remove the menu for now
and deal with that a bit later
just like this alright so here is my my
little side and it doesn't do a lot yet
what you see here is that we have three
blocks here well the menu has been
disappeared but I'll get that back a bit
later but it already is responsive
because what happens here basically is
there is something else that I should
clear out here and that is I need to
compile this one up now again
yeah okay this looks better
so here the other side it doesn't look
really good but it does have some
responsive features here so I have laid
down three content blocks about skeleton
three core principles ducts to support
once I resize the side you'll see that
those blocks will fall underneath each
other at a certain dimension so this is
looking good on any on any device right
now well I do want to change a couple of
things because I've got this hamburger
menu but I only want that hamburger menu
to appear once we are in that small mode
and I want to have the normal menu laid
out in in the current setting I also
want to replace this image by a logo
because our this text by a logo because
it looks a bit better and for that I
will implement a couple of CSS selectors
on this h1 because if we take a look at
the at the master page in this case I
mean this is web fonts but this can be
used with MVC whatever it's just to lay
out this stuff so I want this to be
found good so I've made it a hedge one
but I'm going to put in a couple of
things in my last file which will
replace that logo with some image and I
will be using an SVG version and I will
also be using a PNG version as a
fallback mechanism and I'm declaring a
couple of variables here so I can resize
this I'm going to use these hamburger
things a bit later on and now I can
replace the text or I will position the
the text outside of the container and I
will replace the background with an
image and as you can see I'm just using
those variables here and in this case if
I would save this file
save it again you will see that I have
this h1 replaced with an SVG in this
case because my browser supports SVG and
I've included modernizr to determine
whether that works or not but what I
also want to happen is that once I make
this page smaller that logo can be a bit
smaller so this is also one of the
things that we can do for responsive web
design one of the things that is shipped
with with skeleton as well as Twitter
and the other frameworks is if I go all
the way down we have a number of
specific selectors here now what this
means and this is basically the building
blocks of responsive design first the
top CSS is being applied next the
browser is going to check if any of
these conditions apply to the current
browser and if that is the case so if my
minimum width is smaller as 550 pixels
in this case I will apply additionally
CSS on top of the stuff that we already
loaded and how does that work for
instance so if I add a bit of code here
the header for instance if my screen is
small enough I will apply additional CSS
on that logo and in this case I will
make it flow to the right and I will
scale down that logo and I am using a
mix end that I created myself so let me
put that in here as well and by the way
this code is available on github so you
can download and play with it after the
session I want that that logo to be
skilled in proportionally so it still
looks good so I've created my own little
mix in here with less and I will skill
that logo accordingly so if I save this
let me do this if I save this one out
and do a refresh here what's happening
if my screen gets smaller at a certain
dimension you'll see that the logo gets
smaller and it's flipped over to the
other side because of the additional CSS
that I applied in that media query
that's what we call a media query so
yeah you can do all kinds of stuff with
that I mean I could even make it smaller
if it's like even a smaller device you
can you can play around with that and
you can do all kinds of stuff with that
I also do want to have the navigation
properly set up I do have to keep a bit
track of time so I'm gonna rush this I'm
gonna make the navigation look a bit
better here and there are a couple of
interesting things here that I that I do
I have a normal text specified and I
have a compact text specified and I have
those also specified maybe you'll notice
that already I specified it as well in
the media queries here so basically
everything which has the normal tag
applied will be displayed once the
screen is bigger as 549 pixels
everything which has the complex style
applied hope will have the will be
visible only when you are looking at it
on a small screen and what we can do
with this is let me see if I included
everything I wanted to include for this
stage
yeah so what we see here I left out the
menu there should be a couple of menu
items in here but I left it out because
that that little version conflict once I
make it smaller you'll see that the
hamburger menu will appear so how did
that happen well if we take a look at
the markup here I have decorated
something here so this is a a DIF which
I decorated with a normal tag or the
normal selector and here I decorated
something with the compact I also
included one of those icon fonts and
this is the way how you can use one of
those icon fonts yeah one of those icons
there is this panel and I gave it a icon
- menu which comes out of my fonts which
I downloaded from from ICO moon in this
case it's got it's got all the CSS for
that so if I specify a span with an icon
- menu it will show that hamburger menu
if I would have that font to be bigger
if I want a hamburger menu to be bigger
I can just do some additional styling
here and I can say font size I'm not
sure if this is gonna go look good
if I now switch over and refresh the
page
you
you'll have a bigger hamburger menu so
this is one of the things how you can
make bigger icons with the icon phones
by just specifying the font size it's
it's kind of a blue dash underneath it
and that is because it's an anchor and I
didn't say text decoration is none so
it's it's underlined here so that is
that is in a nutshell how we can apply
certain CSS rules on specific screens
and well the last thing in this in this
little demo that I want to share is that
because the navigation change is what I
would like to happen is that if I am on
a small screen and I click this
hamburger I want to have a menu slide
out from the side and have the
navigation there what you saw at the
site that I was showing you how we can
do this is actually also pretty
straightforward I'll switch back to my
slide deck first to show what we're
gonna do to get that hamburger menu
slide out so what we can do here is I'll
put a div on the left side of my screen
and I'm gonna give it a
position:absolute so I can give it a
minimum height of 100 feet H that's like
a relative measurement and I can have a
width and in the current position it
will have a width of zero pixels so it
will basically not be visible then I
would like to animate it out so I wanted
to ease out that menu I don't want it to
appear like there but I want to have it
animate it and for death I will use
something which is called a CSS
transition to make the width of this
hamburger menu in this case 250 pixels
so I will change the width to 50 but I
will also set up a couple of CSS
transitions specifiers so it will
animate out really nice we don't need
any JavaScript for the animation it will
just be handled by CSS
we will only need a bit of JavaScript to
activate the menu but that is also not
too difficult to to achieve so if I go
back I need to implement that diff first
and again I prepared a bit of code here
so this is going to be the menu the site
menu and I need some CSS here as well
let's put that in the site menu we'll
have basically the stuff that I have
been specifying in the slide deck so I
will have a width of no I will have
position:absolute because if we don't
put a position:absolute you can't use
the z-index to make it go up to the
front and then I will use the the the
transition specifiers and this is
something which is done by CSS and I'm
using a mixin from a lot of file here
but what it basically specifies is that
if I changed by any means the width
property of this particular CSS selector
I want to ease it out I want to use this
animation effect and it needs to happen
in 500 milliseconds so whether I change
it by Firebug or whether I changed it by
JavaScript it will use that animation to
ease out that with so I will make it
wider and that's actually a pretty cool
feature with CSS you don't need any
sophisticated JavaScript to do so you
can just specify this and CSS and it
will happen I will feel them or specify
a couple of other things which need to
happen to have that menu look good and I
will have an additional I will have an
additional selector set up so if I
decorate something outside of the side
menu with this tag and I can use jQuery
to edit ACK
for instance the body element of the
page then it will change the width of
the menu to 250 pixels in this case and
because I specify the transition specify
a right here that is just going to
happen so let me do a couple of things
to see that I didn't forget anything
here I put that one up I put that one up
so let's see what happens if I go back
to my page let's make the hamburger menu
slightly smaller being a bit big right
now which was over here
[Music]
and I put that one here
okay so here it is well I can tell you
that the difference here but nothing is
happening so I need to click this button
and then something needs to happen I'm
going to put a bit of JavaScript inside
this file I did that I prepared it also
already I will start with this menu
function so I will just have a
JavaScript function hamburger feasible
and what it does it adds a class to the
body and in this case it will show left
hamburger menu so in other words if I
would go here to the developer tools and
I would add that manually let me make
that slightly bigger like this I would
go through the particular heads tml let
me make it also slightly bigger so in
this case the body tag doesn't have that
so let me copy that oh let me have a
quick check here show left hamburger
menu it was
I can now add attribute which is going
to be class is show left hamburger menu
you saw the menu pop up and it was nice
and smooth so what I basically did I
just added the shell left hamburger menu
and all the CSS was applied accordingly
so basically what the JavaScript needs
to do is add that thing to the to the
HTML so I set up a couple of small
helper methods here I did some support
for a right side hamburger menu as well
but in that case you can figure that out
yourself you need to have a div on the
other side which has a width of zero
pixels in the beginning but then you
have to change as well the left position
and the width of the right side
hamburger menu but will not be dealing
with that in this session because of
time obviously and I have to really keep
going on the curve because I also want
to show you tell you a bit about
bootstrap so what I've done is I will
I've set up a couple of methods here
which will deck over to a bar click
events to everything which has a data
navigate action in the HTML and I
prepared it obviously already so the
hamburger menu has a data navigate
action and that will toggle hamburger
left just like that so if I switch back
here Safety's JavaScript and reload my
page let me close this one down we'll
have to page again
here's the hamburger menu and here you
go so this is basically in a nutshell
how you could apply stuff like this with
a minimum amount of JavaScript but with
a bit of styling I also did change a
couple of edit a orientation changed as
well and that means that once I resize
the window
I put the width of the menu on zero and
it goes off and that has been done by
binding this code basically so i bided
to an orientation change or resize and
then I will just hide out those
hamburgers so that is in a nutshell what
we can do to make responsive sites and
okay getting getting to bootstrap so why
is bootstrap so popular these days well
a lot of things that I have been doing
like for instance if I go back to my CSS
I pulled in a couple of tricks like for
instance I used something like the
compact class and the normal class so
everything what is decorated with a
normal class in my case will be visible
on a desktop everything which is
decorated with a compact class will be
visible on a smaller device
well bootstrap has way more of those
features specified and that is something
with which makes it really easy to use
so if I check out the bootstrap grid
it's the same as we have so we've got
the columns just like we had on skeleton
we have the rows with elements but the
most interesting things here is that
they have quite a bunch of predefined
class names I hope you can read it
actually so for instance they have a
cold LG for what that means is on a big
device it will spend 4 columns LG stands
for large and they have a whole bunch of
predefined classes which allows you you
only need to decorate certain elements
and it will be visible or non visible
depending on on those prefixes in those
class names so you don't need to pull
those tricks so that is that is one of
the things obviously why bootstrap is
really really easy to use because you
don't have to put in those normal and
compact tricks yourself and well what we
can do is for instance this is a bit of
code concerning bootstrap this is how it
looks and I also put in a bootstrap page
here so if I quickly go to this
particular page you will see that there
is some stuff going on here about the
tricks that I have been pulling off
earlier so that's all out-of-the-box it
works so if I look it up on a small
device you'll have a hamburger menu are
you after menu and I personally don't
like this this kind of thing I like to
slide out more but you could apply the
same code on this bootstrap and able
site as well and if I resize this you'll
see that everything is changing again
but that is because they have all those
predefined Styles already and they're
they're awesome documented so there is
no need to figure out thing you have to
fumble around in the CSS of bootstrap
you can just look that up on the
documentation which styles are available
and again I mean the same principles
apply if I make it smaller you'll see
that all those elements are being put
down to each other so and with bootstrap
for coming out it's got even more of
those features available and it works
even faster and and that kind of stuff
so that is that is one of the reasons
why why bootstrap is doing a good job on
on all those responsive features and
well what I could specify out here is
that I could add like an additional
class here so if I make like a call LG
I don't know eight and I make this one
call LG 2 for instance and again this
needs to add up to 12 because of the
number of columns of the grid then it
should behave differently on a bigger
screen
so I'm I was just putting in a couple of
things I think it should be
yeah so here you
see that then I put it on the big screen
that this one is way bigger as the other
two and that was because of the
additional text that I I only needed to
add those tags so if you know the tags
and their meanings you can do all kinds
of tricks here so that is that is why
bootstrap is quite popular these days
because they've got all of
out-of-the-box
CSS available for you and let me close
down this session right on time with ya
if you have any questions feel free to
ask or come down to our booth and ask
questions there I would like to thank
you so far
[Applause]